Je ressens une frustration un murmure constant
que je ne suis pas plus près de réaliser mes
rêves mis monsieur c'est Shelley
magnifique n'est-il pas juste quel âge avez-vous
alors assez vieux pour savoir pourquoi vous
demandez j'ai 16 ans
quand je me sentais vivant s'en aller  avec
moi
pourquoi êtes-vous vraiment impliqué dans ce
Holman j'ai un feu dans mon âme et
je ne permettrai plus à vous ou à personne d'autre
de le contenir nous avons été invités à Genève
I Lord Byron voudriez-vous attirer
le pollen mademoiselle Oakley I  n'aie aucun scrupule
à ce que tu deviennes amants tu aimerais
être quelqu'un d'autre je ne vois plus le
monde et ça marche ils
m'apparaissaient avant et les hommes m'apparaissaient comme des
monstres oh ouais
chacun pour écrire une histoire de fantôme c'est une
compétition c'est merveilleux Todd elle a
reconnu  Victor Frankenstein ce n'est
pas une histoire de fantômes ça m'a glacé jusqu'aux os
tu dois faire publier ton histoire épouser un
sujet curieux pour jeune
femme suggérez-vous que le travail appartient à
mr.  shell c'est mon histoire
tu oses remettre en question la capacité d'une femme à
vivre une perte
[Musique]
trahison
mort
[Musique]
mes choix ont fait de moi qui je suis
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
toi